je pense qu'il est le film le plus
étrange est le plus interrogatifs de
toute ma vie
il me fascine mais j'ai aussi
l'impression d'être pris pour un con et
quoi qu'il en soit c'est très improbable
de tomber sur un film où la fin est
propre à chacun est donc différent en
fonction de votre pensée toutes les fins
peuvent être bonne en fonction de ce que
vous avez compris
c'est un sentiment réellement étrange
mais on doit alex garland
bref une sorte de météorites tombent sur
la terre et plus précisément dans un
phare situé sur la côte
mais cette météorite amène ce qu'on
appelle le chat y meurt soit en français
le miroitement une zone particulièrement
étrange qui s'étend de jour en jour
cette zone modifie la nature la vie les
cellules l'adn je reste encore tout
bizarre en repensant à ce film et je
n'arrive pas à me sortir de la tête
c'est pourquoi j'aimerais vous proposer
un trois théories le concernant en
rentrant donc dans le miroitement et
attaquons les théories
[Musique]
je dirais que vous confondez suicide
avec autodestruction très peu d'entre
nous peut mettre un suicide et la
majorité d'entre nous auto détruit d'une
certaine manière
à un certain moment dans la vie on boit
on fume on met en péril un boulot en or
ou à couple des plus heureux cette scène
est vraiment révélatrice du film est
plein de philosophie
lena est celle qui a poussé kane à faire
cette mission le couple que nous croyons
heureux a été en fait détruit par
l'infidélité de l'ena envers kane ce
dernier ayant connaissance des actes de
son épouse a décidé de faire cette
mission du chail moeurs n'ayant donc
plus rien à perdre
nous pouvons d'ailleurs le remarquer à
la froideur de kane au moment du départ
les nains comprend donc cette démarche
et entame une sorte de horgues
rédemption envers kane en terminant la
mission qu'il a commencé si nous nous
tournons encore plus dans le côté mental
du film lena était forcément la seule
survivante de la mission non pas car
elle est le personnage principal mais
parce qu'elle n'est plus dans cette
optique d'autodestruction ou suicide
comme elle l'entend josy avait déjà
tenté de se mutiler et donc de se
suicider aller avait déjà accepté sa
mort avant même que la mission commence
et pareil pour vendre 13 qui était prise
d'un cancer bien avancé bien sûr shepard
était dans cette même optique de je n'ai
plus rien à perdre je sais que je ne
reviendrai pas tout ceci est d'ailleurs
compréhensible dans la scène où les nae
shepard échanges entre elles sur la
barque ou comprend que seuls les n'a
hélas pour se racheter
techniquement auprès de kent et qu'elle
possède donc encore l'espoir de revenir
et sauver kane pourquoi irais tel
s'autodétruire dans cette mission alors
qu'il est revenu d'entre les morts au
bout d'un an d'absence simplement à lui
devait bien ça mais ce n'est pas
exactement la théorie dont j'aimerais
vous parler dans cette idée que j'ai
imaginé le cas une présent en train de
se faire soigner serait en fait le
véritable kane et non pas le clown comme
il est sous-entendu pourquoi ça
tout d'abord à la fin nous voyons kane
avoué ne plus savoir où il en est
qu'il ne sait plus qui est réelle ou non
et surtout il demande à son soi-disant
clone de retrouver léna kane d'après moi
était dans la même optique que l'ena il
était fou amoureux d'elle et malgré ses
erreurs il entama un processus
d'autodestruction en effectuant cette
mission comme certains pourraient se
mettre à boire fumer ou pire encore mais
il regretta et dans les moments de doute
de souffrance son coeur se tourne
toujours vers léna kane et donc pas fait
pour mourir
il a même d'ailleurs atteint le phare et
rencontrer l'entité surnaturel qui se
matérialisa en êtres humanoïdes le
copiant physiquement et mentalement
cependant nous ne savons pas combien de
temps kane est resté avec son double
souhaitant apprendre ce qu'est d'être un
humain son double aurait pu ne pas
supporter la souffrance de kane et se
tue à face caméra n'arrivant pas à
devenir un véritable humain ce qui
d'ailleurs appuyé cette idée est que
nous pouvons comparer le caine revenu à
l'ena l'ena n'est clairement plus la
même retour de son expédition
l échange et mentalement j'ai même
d'ailleurs cru qu'elle était le double
au départ laissant la véritable l'ena
mortes dans le phare c'est la même chose
pour kane il est allé effectuer cette
mission le coeur lourd et trahi puis
revient un an plus tard totalement
changé certainement dû à son expédition
et aux chats y meurt quand l'ena demande
à cannes à la fin
je crois pas non
cas il n'aurait changé en revenant de
son expédition ils n'hésitent pas
enlacer l'ena comme s'il l'aimé depuis
le premier jour et qu'il était heureux
de la retrouver
puis ce qui me dérange aussi que kane
tombe gravement malade après être sorti
du charmeur et est soudainement vielvic
en l'entité est détruite
s'il est le clone de kane pourquoi il
n'a pas brûlé comme l'entité copiant
l'ena et comment se fait-il qu'ils
connaissent l'endroit où habitait kane
lna ce n'est mentionné à aucun moment du
film
si nous comparons l'interrogatoire de
l'ena avec celui de kane les deux
semblent aussi perturber l'un que
l'autre
à leur retour enfin la chose que je ne
comprends pas et que nous sommes en
présence d'une seule entité à la fin du
film qui a déjà pris l'apparence de kay
normalement puis quand l'ena arrive elle
est de nouveau présente et prend la
forme de l'ena alors que le clone de
kane existe toujours
peut être car le suicide du clown aurait
pu permettre un reset de son existence
ou peut-être à cause de ventes 13 qui
permis de re créer une entité après
malgré que le film permet d'imaginer
beaucoup de choses des contre arguments
sont présents déjà par rapport aux
vêtements de kane et sa coupe de cheveux
ce ne sont pas les mêmes que celui qui
était de base à l'est dans la zone
c'est d'ailleurs perturbant comparé à
l'ena qui possède une copie conforme
d'elle-même
de plus ce cas il mentionne le fait que
grenade au phosphore une grande lumière
protège ses yeux son double est
incapable de savoir ceci puis le double
de kane en sortant du chail mère tombe
gravement malade
certainement car ils n'arrivent pas à
s'habituer à l'environnement de la terre
mais ils auraient dû normalement partir
quand le shine refus est un d'ailleurs
dans les livres kane se serait
apparemment muté en dauphin ce qui
confirmerait que nous sommes bien en
présence du double dans la zone de
quarantaine ne sait vraiment plus quoi
penser
peut-être qu'au final il est le vrai
double de kane et que c'est au final le
double de l'ena qui a survécu dans le
far et s'en est allé non ce n'est pas
logique
je ne sais plus ce qui est vrai ou faux
vous avez déjà vu une grenade au
phosphore explosé
il est clair que la fin du film nous
confirme que le miroitement est toujours
présent lenaï le double de kane ce qui
est normal pour lui après tout donc nous
pouvons clamer haut et fort que toute
cette histoire reviendra et n'est pas
encore finie je ne suis pas sûr qu'un
annihilation 2 verra le jour
mais quelle conséquence engendre cette
fin tout d'abord nous savons que l'ena
est obsédé par l'immortalité
elle affirme toujours que nos cellules
sont la cause de notre finalité est que
si elle se répare est constamment nous
pourrions vivre éternellement
elle en parle très souvent elie même des
magazines à ce sujet le miroitement
permet de modifier génétiquement toutes
espèces vivantes vivant dans le charmeur
nous le remarquons tout le long du film
avec par exemple le crocodile avec la
dentition d'un requin les fleurs ou
encore fucking ours qui me donne froid
dans le dos qui possède la voix de
shepard
certainement car il l'a tout au niveau
du cou et donc des cordes vocales enfin
bref j'ai pas envie de parler de lui le
miroitement permet donc d'évoluer et
donc de modifier nos cellules chose que
l'humain a très peur
l'évolution contrairement à léna kane
étant le double du véritable kane
normalement est la source du chail
moeurs et possède donc le miroitement en
lui c'est logique
lena séparer de son côté suite à la fin
du film où elle est allée à la source du
phare elle est infecté par le
miroitement aussi et depuis qu'elle est
infectée un tatouage est apparue au
niveau de son bras
symbolisant lauro boros un serpent qui
se mord la queue
sa position forme l'infini donc
l'immortalité et le fait qu'il se mange
là que symbolise l'autodestruction de
thématiques importantes du film ce
détail qu'elle ne possédait pas
auparavant peut largement signifie que
l'ena et maintenant immortel car ces
cellules se régénère éternellement à
cause du mérou battement présent en elle
ce tatouage était à l'origine sur le
bras dania mais suite aux chômeurs et
aux péripéties du film il est apparu sur
le bras de l'ena un détail et un message
caché affirmant son éternité et donc son
éternelle jeunesse puisque ces cellules
se re fabrique constamment maintenant la
présence du miroitement en kane elena
nous affirme que l'entité a gagné entre
guillemets puisque elle toujours
présente et que le miroitement re fera
donc son apparition en nous affirme tout
le long du film compte c'est parce que
cette chose voulez ou s'il voulait
quelque chose on ne sait absolument rien
de lui
non qu'on ne peut rien affirmer sur lui
toutes les théories le concernant sont
donc possibles dont celle d'une sorte d'
invasion extraterrestre puisque le
scheiber reviendra forcément avec les
nike m le but de cet être est donc
peut-être de modifier la nature et la
vie de la terre et qu'il a appris de son
échec face à l'ena car ils ne
réussissent à pas à devenir humain c'est
en fait avoir par l'ena justement
contrairement à kane qui lui a appris à
devenir un humain et à devenir lui même
en prenant son identité
un mystère a jamais non résolus puisque
rien n'a été confirmé sur le film même
les acteurs possèdent leur propre
conception de la fin j'aime cette idée
de partir de rien et concevoir sa propre
vision
[Musique]
ceci est une cellule
pour finir j'aimerais vous proposer une
autre vision du film le film commence
avec l'arrivée de la météorite du chail
meurt sur la terre puis enchaîne avec un
cours de l'ena une ancien militaire
devenu professeur de biologie où elle
parle d'une tumeur d'une femme le film
traite par moments de cancer ou de
tumeurs la terre avance normalement dans
le temps et vit entre guillemets au jour
le jour mais cette météorite tombe sur
terre et provoque une sorte de
dysfonctionnements de cette dernière
modifiant et perturbant toute la vie qui
l'entourent et chose encore plus
surprenante cette zone créée par le
shine moeurs étant constamment de jour
en jour jusqu'à un moment où la terre
sera engloutie par cette zone et cette
maladie de la terre s'adapte à son
environnement en essayant de copier ce
qui l'habite je pense que vous avez
compris où je voulais en venir le
miroitement est en fait la métaphore
d'un cancer la météorite arrivant sur la
terre symbolise l'arrivée du cancer dans
le corps humain
ce dernier provoque un dysfonctionnement
exactement comme dans le corps humain
il modifie et perturbe les cellules de
notre corps est justement ces cellules
sont en fait symbolisée par la vie
présente sur terre notre corps est
composé de milliers de milliards de
cellules regroupés pour former les
tissus et les organes les gènes présents
dans le noyau de chaque cellule lui
indique qu'en se développer travailler
se diviser et mourir en temps normal nos
cellules suivre ses directives et nous
restons en santé mais lorsque notre adn
et modifier ou endommagé un gène peut
subir une mutation les gènes mutés ne
fonctionne pas correctement parce que
les directives dans leur adn sont
confuses
ainsi les cellules qui devrait se
reposer pourrait se diviser et croître
de façon désordonnée ce qui peut mener
au cancer à des modifiés ou endommagés
cela ne vous rappelle pas quelque chose
chaque être vivant sur terre est là pour
une bonne raison on peut prendre
l'exemple d'un lion qui tue une gazelle
il permet de se nourrir mais dans même
temps éviter que trop de gaz elles
peuplent la terre ils sont comparables
aux cellules permettant de faire
fonctionner un être vivant c'est la loi
de la nature et marche pour chaque être
vivant
cependant vu que leur adn est modifié et
même
endommagée par le miroitement la terre
se porte mal dans la partie où est
présente le charmeur comme le crocodile
requins les fleurs ou ce fameux [ __ ]
d'ours toute la faune et la flore est
perturbé et provoque donc un
dysfonctionnement qui s'étend de plus en
plus chaque jour
exactement comme un cancer qui se
développe dans le corps humain grâce à
la perturbation des cellules présentes
alors oui on ne sait pas ce que voulait
cette entité extraterrestre ou si elle
voulait quelque chose mais c'est tout
simplement comme un cancer est ce que le
cancer possède un but
est-ce qu'il veut quelque chose non il
est une maladie juste se développer et
qui provoque un dysfonctionnement
exactement comme le miroitement au final
ce dernier essaye de d'ailleurs
apprendre de son environnement en
copiant les cellules de la terre soit
les humains et la vie qui entoure notre
planète
annulation n'est pas un film comme les
autres et il m'a marqué je le range dans
cette catégorie de films comme
interstellar ou premier contact traitant
de science fiction en essayant de rester
dans le réel et qui donc nous amène à
une grosse réflexion
ce sont en général mes films préférés
d'ailleurs j'espère que ma vidéo vous
aura plu
merci à ceux qui laisseront un pouce
bleus et qui partageront cette vidéo
suivez moi sur twitter c'est important
dites moi ce que vous avez pensé de ce
film en commentaire et quels sont vos
théories je serai curieux de lire votre
vision par rapport aux sujets que le
line up soit avec vous et à oui vous
avez déjà vu l'explosion d'une grenade
au phosphore
[Musique]